I love my electric bike I love it so
much I wish sometimes I could just cycle
forever so I bought a solar panel
attached it to the back of my bike and
in this video I'm going to see how far I
can cycle without running out of charge
I'm going to be cycling largely along
the kennet and even Canal path it runs
from Bath to reading and then I'll be
finishing the route on some main roads
aiming for the center of London and
specifically Big Ben there were however
a few things I didn't expect my panel's
getting Dusty I'm gonna have to clean it
off the path here is so
this is tough tougher than I was
imagining oh that's not good that's
really not good second battery has just
conked out in the middle of nowhere
sixty percent charge left 12 percent
focus on battery five percent
oh my God I actually made it